I love that it sorts of story wood shows
that young women is felt very empowering
I felt really in my body the fate of
humanity is now in your hands you know
young girls and boys seeing that it was
finally a female protagonist in a video
game and he was groundbreaking back then
it's been a step-by-step process in
history and now it's wonderful whilst we
were shooting this I I went to the
cinema watch Wonder Woman and sat there
just enjoying yeah seeing these battles
in a way that I have never experienced
and growing up I never thought that this
day would happen yeah and then to be
part of this film which also kind of
shows a young girl finding her footing
in the world and become this action area
that she's so well known to be that
meant a lot things you need to know
before going to see Tomb Raider number
one bring a flashlight
close the tomb once and hold number two
make sure you stand behind Lara Croft
number three a bottle of water
we fought to try and give you something
fresh and new and give you more elements
of Laura so please go and watch our film
can't be too careful these days the
world has gone bloody mad I'll take two
you
[Music]